chuckle did you ever use jujitsu in
combat wouldn't a striking art be better
for combat situations okay so yes and
definitely this is one of the things
where I was actually I read things about
this and people say well no I mean why
would a seal ever have to use you know
hand-to-hand combat they have a rifle
they have a pistol
they've got buddies with them so you if
you've if you have to use your hand to
hand combat you've done something wrong
mm-hm and that's actually completely
wrong because you know it's very simple
you go into a room where there's people
in there and none of them are armed and
you have to get control of them you
can't just start shooting people you're
gonna have to get control them so how do
you get control of them well again
how does striking give you control of
someone the answer is it does not unless
you have a miracle touch that you can
just knock people out with one touch and
then you can handcuff them people don't
boxers don't knock each other out
consistently you know it's it's very
difficult to knock someone out and so
this idea that you know striking is
better you absolutely have to know how
to strike but striking is a very very
inconsistent way to get control of
somebody very very inconsistent way to
of controlling people and actually the
the sad thing is is that it's striking
is the most traumatic to the to the
person that you're applying it to and
you know we used to do something or we
were taught something called a muzzle
strike right well you basically hit the
person with the muzzle of your gun and
the people that were teaching it would
be like thinking that that just stopped
people hmm like yo you give him one good
muzzle strike because it does it seems
like you know a muzzle is a very strong
I mean a very small point of impact and
you think all if I put all my force
behind this small point of impact Matt's
really gonna you'll hurt somebody and
take them down and I saw hundreds of
muzzle strikes and they're really brutal
and they what what they do is they cut
you they cut you open very badly as a
lot
really bad cuts were like a rifle rifle
and but they seldom did they actually
knock the person out so what do you do
then
you muscle strike him again and then
what do you do after that you muscle
strike him again what do you do so you
end up just beating leaving them but
it's but it's a harsh beating because
you using a you know a pretty sharp
muzzle of a weapon which is cutting them
open so it's it's it's not the best
whereas if someone can get controlled
somebody in a grappling type scenario
get control them you know clinch with
them take them down quickly you can get
controlled very quick quickly and they
feel it and they resist less because
they kind of feel owned and they also
don't feel like you're hurting them
whereas when you're striking them in the
face man what's your natural answer
reaction if I strike you in the face
you're gonna put your hands up well if
you put your hands up maybe you're
trying to attack me now I got a hit you
even harder so it's a it's kind of a
kind of a bad deal so yeah and then once
you get person on the ground obviously
the more you know the better you're
gonna do and that's why you know it's
good it's good to have that
well-roundedness but you definitely want
to use you know you definitely wanna
have a good ground game you want to have
good striking - of course and but the
jiu-jitsu and the ground the ground game
is very important because you've got to
control people and in a combat situation
everybody you come up against is not a
combatant and they still need to get
controlled and some people you can just
motion to them to get down and that's
great and then you can tell them to lay
down and that's great and you can have
your interpreter tell them to put their
hands behind their back and then that's
great or you can say that you know you
can learn a few phrases which we always
did we always knew a few phrases to tell
them to you know get down show me your
hands or whatever but then you get the
person that maybe they don't respond to
what you're saying
and why aren't they responding and this
is something I see you know in some of
these police videos when I yell at you
you know get out get out well you might
be scared you might not know what I'm
talking about you might have headphones
on you might be deaf
you might just be frozen with fear you
might be a bad guy you might be getting
ready to run all those different things
but if you're not doing what I tell you
I gotta get you to the ground so how am
I gonna do that and again I can walk up
and take a swing at you but you know
I've been punched in the face many many
times haven't been knocked out but twice
so all the times I've been punched in
the face you know many many times I
don't know how many but many many times
it's hard to knock someone else so if
you think cuz you walk over and strike
someone you're gonna knock them out then
you're gonna have control it's not true
it's just a fallacy so you're gonna have
to know some and that the thing this all
goes back to this you know this case and
I forget what the case was but somebody
got choked years ago like in the 70s by
a police officer and I think they died
or whatever but they banned choking they
banned choking from most police forces
so that's why these guys what do they do
they pull out their batons and start
beating people that was a big big thing
with Rodney King you know why didn't
someone just go and put this guy to
sleep yeah and he'd have no marks on his
body you know he'd be okay you could
bring him back to the jail cell he's not
gonna have contusions he's not gonna
have the crappy down we have no
permanent damage whatsoever
hmm but it wasn't allowed because of the
because of the political situation that
it happened years before you weren't
allowed to teach someone how to choke
someone who put them to sleep and
completely incapacitate them yeah I mean
the choke hold is a beautifully powerful
thing and when you have when you have
them you saw the Rodney King tape I mean
there's how many cops or but there's
multiple cops beating him that's a
classic example of what I'm saying just
because you strike someone doesn't even
with a billy club doesn't mean they're
gonna stop whereas when you put a
chokehold on somebody they are going to
sleep you know they they are going to
sleep 100% yeah and when you have three
cops going against one guy someone's
gonna get a choke hold on yeah you know
and and despite what they did to Rodney
King beating him he wasn't stopping and
so yeah it's one of those things I
really hope that the that the law
enforcement gets the ability to use to
train better to use choke holds to use
other forms of grappling because it is
absolutely superior from
forcement perspective and from and from
even from like I said from a military
perspective when you go into a room and
there's non-combatants in there that you
have to get control over you don't want
to start beating people you know you
want to use the minimum required force
and yet when people aren't compliant you
have to be able to do something yeah so
yeah the the minimum required force that
essentially makes striking obsolete if
you're trying to approach it that way or
if that's the regulation you know if
it's not the regulation if you're if
you're a human yeah and you've got a
woman that is scared or doesn't speak
your language or is petrified or
whatever the case may be your answer is
to strike her in the face and what is by
the way what does her husband do when
you strike her in the face yeah as
opposed to if you come over you put your
hands on or you gently push to the
ground you feel some resistance maybe
you have to do some sort of manipulation
of a joint to get to control but that is
so much more mild than a muzzle strike
to the face yeah and if you know what to
do if you know jiu-jitsu it's a
no-brainer yeah and it's not hard to do
to people and even and you'll see
sometimes when someone's trying to get
you know gain control and I'll put their
arm behind their back like chicken wings
situation they'll do it all hard like
real hard yeah because they kind of got
to add that element of pain so the guy
will kind of quote-unquote know most
jujitsu stuff you don't have to put that
pain it's just that controlling like you
just can't that's why a lot of people
were talking about this today how a lot
of people after they get their first
time in jujitsu or something or early on
and you do to a guy will tap them out
and they'll have this thing in their
mind like oh I just have to go harder
you know I I can just I can gain some
kind of control just got to go harder
but it because it's not a hard thing
it's not a like aggressive feeling to
get controlled like that you just simply
controlled and you know this ties so
much to life yes we talked about I mean
you hear me talk about this whole time
and I was going back and forth with
somebody on Twitter the other day about
I'm like you gotta use the indirect
approach with people so picture this
next time you're dealing with
person that's combative and I mean now
I'm talking about verbally combative or
their their ideas are combative against
your competitive's is the first thing
you want to do go up and punch him in
the face or muzzle strike them right
because what is their reaction going to
be what the reaction is gonna be
mediately be defensive you don't want to
put people in that predicament mmm you
want to use the jujitsu on them you
wanna you want to get them feeling
comfortably when you're going to sleep
you when you're somebody puts a
chokehold on you you're done I mean
you're just going to sleep you sneak in
behind so so don't get this idea that
when you're dealing with people in a
confrontation not only physically but a
verbal or a mental confrontation and I'm
not even talking about a confrontation
in you know yelling in the street I'm
talking about in the office I'm talking
about dealing with one of your
subordinates I'm talking about dealing
with your boss or whoever think about
using instead of thinking about hey I'm
gonna you know smash this person in the
face and that's gonna bring me the win
no it's not generally it is not
generally what brings you the win is
okay hey where's what's going on let's
sneak in there let's get inside their
head let's let's not aggravate the
situation yeah let's bring the situation
towards a better area where we can use
our control yeah you won't get the win
you'll get a fight oh yeah you'll
definitely get a fight even though
that's not that cool yeah you'd be if
they are combative and your answer is to
be more combative you know that's right
yeah you know their answers yeah even
more comments oh yeah then you got
yourself a fight Henner in them and
Gracie's there doing good stuff with law
enforcement commuting jujitsu an actual
police tactics so it comes from you know
it's in context and then you know
whatever your if you're a police officer
out there or you're in law enforcement
in you know and ER
that's great guess what there's a
jiu-jitsu studio everywhere in the
country right now go train some
jiu-jitsu just go start training no big
deal just go start training yeah and I
have a friend Craig he's from from from
Hawaii he um
good cop you see him on Facebook I all
like repo stuff sometimes so like he'll
come down to the skate park whether you
know he got called or whatever posted
yeah and he'll be reading yeah skating
or he'll race somewhere but Aires but
he's either jujitsu I think he's a
purple or brown yeah so he has the
confidence yeah man that's what it is he
has the confidence that's awesome you
know be be a good guy you know good guy
with the power